Vous a-t-on déjà appelé quelque chose que vous n'êtes pas ?
Voici ce que ça me fait :
immédiatement, je deviens une tempête interne d'émotions contradictoires.
J'éclate dans une sueur qui est une combinaison de rage et d'humiliation,
je sens que le magasin entier m'observe,
et en même temps, je me sens invisible.
Je veux exploser dans une tirade de fureur,
et je veux ramper sous un rocher.
Et pour couronner le tout, la frustration de porter
un t-shirt violet moulant qui n'est pas mon style,
et le magasin entier peut voir mes seins,
pour m'assurer que cette chose même ne se produise pas.
(Rires)
Mais malgré mes meilleurs efforts pour être vue selon le sexe que je suis,
ça arrive encore.
Et j'espère de tout mon cœur que personne n'a entendu —
pas ma sœur, ma petite amie et certainement pas ma nièce.
Je suis habituée à cette douleur familière,
mais je ferai tout ce que je peux pour en protéger les gens que j'aime.
Mais alors j'ôte ma nièce de mes épaules,
et elle court vers Elsa et Anna —
ce qu'elle a attendu pendant si longtemps —
et tout s'en va.
Tout ce qui m'importe est le sourire sur son visage.
Tandis que les 30 secondes
pour lesquelles nous avons attendu deux heures et demi s'achèvent,
nous rassemblons nos affaires, et je fixe à nouveau des yeux l'employée ;
et elle me fait un sourire d'excuse et murmure :
« Je suis tellement désolée ! »
(Rires)
Et son humanité, sa volonté d'admettre son erreur me désarment immédiatement.
Puis je lui dis : « C'est pas grave, ça arrive. Mais merci. »
Et je réalise à ce moment
que je n'ai pas à choisir entre tante et militante,
je peux être les deux.
Je peux vivre en dualité, et je peux être deux choses.
Et si je peux être deux choses dans cet environnement,
je peux en être bien plus.
Tandis que ma petite amie et ma nièce sautillent vers la sortie,
je me tourne vers ma sœur et dit : « Est-ce que ça valait le coup ? »
Et elle répond : « Tu plaisantes ? As-tu vu sa tête ?
C'était le plus beau jour de sa vie ! »
(Rires)
« Ça valait les deux heures et demi dans la chaleur,
ça valait l'album de coloriage hors de prix que nous avions déjà.
(Rires)
Ça valait même qu'on t'appelle Papa. »
Et pour la toute première fois de ma vie,
ça valait en effet le coup.
Merci, Boulder. Passez une bonne soirée.
(Applaudissements)